welcome to age a plus for your talk I'm
damu this is my good friend Tareq and
we're talking about Peggy Hubbard she's
the grandmother from East st. Louis she
had a lot to say that about the black
lives matter movement she called a bunch
of hypocrites liars and she said
basically where are they you got take a
look at this side I'm taking covered
you're hauling this black lives matter
bullshit it don't matter you killing
each other you black people my black
people you are the most violent because
I have ever seen in my life Terry what
do you think about that and you black
people what you know what I mean I think
she was clearly very upset when she
recorded that you know I think maybe
perhaps she said things that she didn't
mean to say well you don't see if she
was upset about two cases that happened
in st. Louis won a nine-year-old girl
who was killed by a stray bullet from a
drive-by shooting and a young man who
allegedly was carrying a gun was killed
by the police so she saw that black
lives matter activists were protesting
the young man put out the young girl
that's what she's upset about but for me
it's not it's not like a reasonable
argument because black lives matter is
specifically a black about police
brutality right no joining us via Skype
from the black lives matter movement we
have Mara willow you guys might remember
moral she was young lady that actually
went to the Bernie Sanders rally in
Seattle she grabbed the microphone so
Mara joining us tomorrow how are you I
am doing well so you saw this the video
of Peggy harbor we mean was your
reaction to that you know well I like
first of all I'd like to focus on the
problem right which is white supremacy
and anti blackness and which is both
foundational to our country as well as
globally is an issue so I don't think
that there's actually a lot of Merit in
focusing on this one woman I think that
her comments do reveal a lot about the
state of our country um and I think
that's worth talking about bit I don't
think that there's a lot of Merit in
in fixating on her as an individual and
I think it reveals a lot about the way
that the media you know does uphold
systemic racism and the ways that the
media perpetuates violence it gets the
plot unity well let me ask you this
though really quick then um so you go to
a Bernie Sanders rally which is
predominantly kind of far left everybody
I was to most people next I wouldn't
consider sells races and what were the
you know supporters like who or
non-black what was their reaction to you
grabbing Bernie Sanders Mike I mean I
think at this point everyone has read
and seen what the reaction was I think
everyone has you know seeing the the
changes that Bernie Sanders has made to
his platform as a result of our action
so I'm very proud of our action in
Seattle that day and I'm very proud of
myself and my team but were you
surprised by the response at the Bernie
Sanders rally I wasn't surprised we
needed the action would be controversial
we knew that people would be upset there
be white tears everywhere I don't see
that there's anything that can really
prepare you to have thousands of white
people standing and yelling at you for
you to be arrested for you to be tased
that's really what it felt like
especially during that four and a half
minute moment of silence that we
insisted on holding for michael ground
the day before at the anniversary of his
death now that four and a half minute
moment of silence was really difficult
got it well tomorrow black lives matter
has been around for a little while now
it's been a year since it really picked
up in the media so like a year on how do
you think things are going to develop
for your movement what is the next step
you know it's hard to say if not it's
not up to any one individual or any one
organization or network to determine
what black self-determination looks like
I think that this you know this 2016
presidential election is really
interesting
and it'll be interesting to see how
people within the movement decide to and
create or not engage in that system I do
think that shutdowns are important I do
think that on the disruptions that klm
is kind of known for I think that those
have proven to be really effective
similarly to how boycotts are really
effective during the civil rights
movement at the same time I think that
there isn't enough solidarity work being
done with the formerly incarcerated and
currently incarcerated black folks who
are also part of our community whether
we see them like that or not yo bar
thank you so much for joining us we
really appreciate it and I swear I
really hope Donald Trump come to Seattle
I really want to do was she gonna go to
I hope so too yeah it will see you he's
about that you know he's not that life
grantham I can drop it you know to me so
all right thank you again one all right
all right thank you guys have a good
weekend
you